utiliza estos triángulos este triángulo
verde y este triángulo amarillo para
formar un rectángulo como es un
rectángulo pues es una figura geométrica
con cuatro lados dos lados más largos y
dos lados más cortos veamos con esta
primera opción usaron los dos triángulos
para formar un triángulo más grande pero
nos están pidiendo un rectángulo éste
tiene tres lados así que no es
rectángulo no lo voy a seleccionar
aquí pues como que los pusieron juntos
pero realmente no están formando una
figura geométrica para nada están
formando un rectángulo esta tercera
opción está si es la correcta
aquí están los dos triángulos el
triángulo amarillo el triángulo verde y
juntos forman una figura con uno dos
tres cuatro lados dos lados más largos y
dos más cortos este es un rectángulo la
selección amos y comprobamos nuestra
respuesta
es correcta vemos la siguiente pregunta
ahora realicemos este otro ejercicio nos
dicen utiliza estos cuadrados este color
como gris y este morado para formar un
rectángulo veamos las opciones en esta
primera opción pues no estamos formando
un rectángulo porque ni siquiera están
unidos
estos dos cuadrados están separados y no
están alineados así que esta no es esta
otra si tengo estos dos cuadrados que
están unidos y me están formando este
rectángulo este cuadrilátero que tiene
uno dos tres cuatro lados y dos de sus
lados son más largos y los otros dos son
más pequeños esta es la opción correcta
pero voy a revisar esta otra pues aquí
unieron los dos cuadros pero pues
realmente en figura geométrica no han
formado ninguna así que ésta no es
comprobamos la respuesta
es correcta veamos la siguiente pregunta
ahora nos dicen utiliza estos pequeños
rectángulos aquí tengo un rectángulo y
otro rectángulo este rojo y este azul
para formar un rectángulo grande veamos
las opciones
mi primera opción tengo este rectángulo
este otro pero no está formando un
rectángulo grande nada más están juntos
pero no están alineados así que este no
es en esta opción pues no están formando
un rectángulo están formando algo
parecido a una l así que esta tampoco es
esta opción si aquí tengo los dos
rectángulos que están juntos y alineados
y me están formando un rectángulo
selecciono la opción y vamos a revisar
si es correcta comprobamos respuesta
es correcta